you see this movie right I don't think I  have oh dude no I think this is why I'm  so violent mentally because of this  movie yeah bro now that looks like a  Saturday yeah yeah yeah that's a  Saturday the line after he gets hit by  this is so wild he sits over this and he  goes I'm gonna murder that kid Jesus  yeah dude I remember laughing my ass off  as a kid I'm gonna murder that kid it's  a dark ass movie bro there's one point  where Kevin McAllister tries to get into  this taxi cab and he's like oh it's  scary out there this dude turns around  with like a shot out eyeball he's like  it ain't much better in here kid the  whole movie is so cruel what else does  he do to them what's the most violent  thing dude that was pretty bad he lights  them on fire twice Marv getting  electrocuted that [ __ ] is straight up  the electric chair Jesus Christ